quem é que alguma vez já se deixou levar
pela visão de alguém sobre alguma coisa
muita gente né
alguns anos atrás eu tinha acabado de
concluir o ensino fundamental com 13
anos na época e tinha me decidido que a
concorrer uma vaga pra estar na escola
técnica mas com ser muito nova e eu não
pude concorrer essa vaga
eu me desesperei por que sobrava pra mim
apenas a escola de ensino médio tida
como a pior da região e que era
inexpressivo em todos os aspectos
possíveis
depois de muito refletir sobre o que as
pessoas me falavam eu comecei a me
questionar sobre o que era verdade e o
que eu poderia fazer para mudar essa
realidade
e foi esse o desafio que decide encarar
já no primeiro semestre eu percebi que
sim
muito do que me falavam sobre a escola
era verdade
por exemplo os alunos eram desmotivados
a escola inexpressivo em questão a
projetos científicos
a feira de ciências da escola era
obrigatória e os alunos só fazer um
projeto na base do control c control v
copiados da internet e ainda faziam só
para obter nota
conversando com um grupo de amigos mas
sabemos que esse era o motivo da
inexpressividade da escola em relação a
projetos científicos nas feiras da
região
depois de meses pensando nós resolvemos
criar um projeto que não fosse baseado
no control c control v copiados da
internet é nós começamos a conversar e
criamos um projeto que levasse para as
pessoas o conhecimento sobre a história
do nosso município cascavel ceará pois
depois de uma pesquisa em campo com os
moradores alunos mas sabemos que 80% dos
moradores não conheciam sobre a história
do município não sabe onde nada então
depois de muito trabalhar depois de
muito pesquisar foram meses pesquisando
levantando fontes e do em campo mas
resolvemos criar todo esse trabalho
dentro de um cordel
o cordel literatura muito comum no
nordeste e que serve muito pra dinamizar
o conhecimento levar o conhecimento para
as pessoas depois depois nós fizemos
esse projeto chegou o momento de
apresentar na escola que ficou foi muito
tenso pra gente porque era a primeira
vez mas nós batalhamos muito trabalhamos
muito e conseguimos o primeiro lugar e o
direito de representar nossa escola
feira regional
até então a nossa escola já tinha esse
direito mas quando a gente chegava lá
gente não queria sair de lá com o
terceiro lugar é óbvio mas queremos sair
de lá com o primeiro mas ficamos com o
pensamento do terceiro já que a gente
nunca teria conseguido antes e por
incrível que pareça a gente saiu de lá
com o primeiro lugar
aquilo foi a realização de um sonho
porque isso nunca tinha acontecido então
depois que nós ganhamos o primeiro lugar
nós tivemos a oportunidade de
representar nossa escola uma feira
estadual que reúne os melhores projetos
do estado ceará
a gente ficou nossa que a gente vai
fazer lá meu deus
mas a gente foi a gente não dá choques
nos abalar se porque a gente queria
mostrar que por mais que a nossa escola
fosse a pior da região poderia sair um
projeto bacana e quando chegamos lá nós
apresentamos as pessoas gostavam muito
nosso projeto os olhos brilhavam ea
gente ficava emocionada com isso que a
gente queria ser reconhecida e de novo
nós conseguimos o primeiro lugar e o
direito de representar nossa escola uma
feira nacional ea gente ficou meu deus
mais uma vez conseguiu depois daí a
gente não queria só apresentar projetos
não era só essa transformação que a
gente queria nós queremos levar essa
transformação pra dentro da nossa escola
não queria que isso acontecesse só
comigo e sim com os meus colegas com os
alunos tanto na escola como na região
então nós vamos conversar com nossa
diretoria área que ela está aqui
presente e ela super apoiou e disse que
sim o aluno deveria ter vez e voz na
escola ela tomou a decisão que foi muito
chocante para os professores que era
deixar que os alunos
tivessem participação presente nas
decisões escolares ou seja tudo o que
fosse decidido na escola tinha que ter
um aluno presente no começo os
professores ficaram meio assim aos
alunos vão participar tiveram a
resistência mas depois eles super
aceitaram e disseram que os projetos
terão que ser desenvolvidos a partir de
problemas da comunidade e da escola e
deu muito certo nós conseguimos muito
resultado
depois de passar essa metodologia para a
nossa escola mas fomos premiados em mais
de dez eventos científicos nacionais
internacionais e fomos finalistas e
premiado projeto criativo da escola que
é um projeto maravilhoso que fala sobre
ativismo social
a gente pensa que a gente não pode mudar
pelo simples fato de outra pessoa achar
que você não pode mudar é o caso do ici
não deixa que o citi perturbe o mundo
precisa que a gente mostra a gente pode
se mudar
a gente pode se transformar o que está
ao nosso redor
não deixe que o citi perturbe tenta
acredita ousa arrisca erra mas volta a
gente precisa disso não importa se isso
vai impactar mil ou um milhão de pessoas
acredita arregaça as mangas e faz
obrigado
[Aplausos]